an illegal alien just followed a u.s
senator democrat kirsten cinema into a
public bathroom to harass her about an
upcoming vote and to demand amnesty and
a pathway to citizenship
elected we can get you out of office if
you don't support what you promised us
we need seven million citizenship for
seven million we need the belgrave right
now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old
and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sc 1070 and i'm here
because i definitely believe that we
need this pathway to citizenship my
grandfather passed away two weeks ago
and i was not able to go to mexico and
visit him because there is no pathway to
citizenship and if we have the
opportunity to pass it right now then we
need to do it because there's millions
of undocumented people just like me who
share the same story or even worse
things that happened to them because of
sb 1070 and because of anti-immigrant
legislation
in a serious country
this woman would be deported before she
could say ola muchacho
but because we are not a serious country
at the moment she won't be in fact she's
being applauded by a lot of the american
left she is not worried
at all
she is so unconcerned about being held
to account for this serious crime that
she is currently committing that she is
flaunting it right in front of one of
the nation's supposedly most powerful
lawmakers and it isn't just illegal
aliens it's the media it's the
entrenched interests it's the exalted dr
fauci flaunting their expanding and
illegitimate power and laughing because
there's nothing you can do about it this
woman
this illegal alien lady
who doesn't sound like a three-year-old
i don't know about you she says i was
brought here when i was three and she's
still got quite a bit of an accent so
she hasn't learned a ton of english
perhaps maybe she's learned the english
but she hasn't assimilated quite so much
during all that time since she's been
three years old she is now complaining
that she's not allowed to come and go as
she's in this country illegally she's
not allowed to come and go as she
pleases because if she leaves people
might realize at the border that she's a
foreign national and has no right to be
in this country and so they might not
let her back in but she wants to stay in
so she doesn't get to go on vacation she
doesn't get to leave the country
she doesn't get to go see her family
outside of the country right your
family's outside of the country because
that's where that's where you guys are
citizens
and then some people broke the law and
came here illegally and now you're
complaining about this further further
do you hear what she says at the
beginning
she and her friends say we put you in
office we got you elected and we're
going to get you kicked out of office
admitting that illegal aliens are
affecting our elections
she's saying i'm an illegal alien i put
you into office
why is that in part it's because some
illegal aliens are voting we know that
for sure we know that they're affecting
the election in other ways they're going
door-to-door they're canvassing they're
interfering in the election process i
don't want to hear a word about how
someone's colluding with the russians
which isn't even happening or ukrainian
interference or russian interference or
whatever
when we have
millions and millions and millions of
foreign nationals
influencing our elections right here in
the united states what happened to our
democracy isn't the bedrock principle of
our democracy that the citizens get to
conduct their own elections
no not not in this country
in this country this woman is so
feels so easy that she's going to go
walk up to a top
lawmaker in the united states and say ha
ha i'm breaking the law hahaha hey make
it easier to break the law it shows you
also how they've shifted the overton
window here on the left initially
what people would call for in this case
is deport deport her and deport all of
the other people who are breaking the
law by being in this country then the
argument moved to look let them stay
don't deport all of them deport the
really bad ones but let the other ones
stay and they'll keep their heads down
and it's fine and because we acknowledge
birthright citizenship in this country
and we are fairly confident in that for
the past at least recent decades then
that's fine
now we've moved it all the way over to
give them amnesty or they'll harass
senators in the bathroom
does that seem like the right thing to
do compassionate just i don't think so
it's not just the illegal aliens i mean
this woman should be deported
you know by the end of this program but
it's not just the illegal aliens and
it's not just the people encouraging
illegal immigration it's the whole
liberal apparatus i'm glad you like that
clip get the whole show either here at
the michael knowles show on youtube or
at apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type it in the michael knowles
show subscribe
click that button we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]